All right guys here. We are we are in the jungle. We are deep in the jungle
I believe I am discovering new land new territories. You can see this as real as it gets
I have had no water no food
I have been catching fish with my bare hands that I do not even recognize they have three heads. I am hallucinating out here
I have had zero contact with the outside world, and that's a
yes, we just keep that on me, you didn't see that, like I was saying I'm discovering new land welcome to Jumanji you ruined A
Shot son of a bitch you're ruining shot. Oh
Ahhh, production just got shut down
here on a set of Jumanji
It's not cos of weather not because of the crazy
environment that we're shooting in
it's because Jack Black needed to finish his rice!
Jack you good? I'm good!  Yeah, Jack said I'm not shooting shit
til I finished my damn rice, ain't that right jack? This some good stuff. That's right, Jack said you can kiss my ass
Production can wait! You okay Jack?
Woah.. Hey big guy.  Ready to shoot?  Coming now
The jungles of Jumanji are amazing, but you got to be careful cuz a lot of mosquitoes and the skeets come out at night
Skeets come at night. The skeets come out at night.  The skeets come out at night.  The skeets come out!
All right, it's 3:00 a.m.. On set. We just wrapped here on Jumanji these fans right here
I got the greatest fans in the world. They have literally been waiting out here somewhere. I don't know 9
12 hours or something like that, here they are right here
(Screaming) Appreciate you guys
All right all right good to meet you. Good night